Taylor Swift is going on her biggest
tour ever did you guys know that she's
won more music awards than Michael
Jackson and is the highest paid female
singer of all time jealous you can hate
her all you want she'll just Shake It
Off Taylor Swift technically started her
music career all the way back in 2002
when she sang the national anthem at a
basketball game for the Philadelphia
76ers and two years later at age 14 she
was briefly signed to Sony ATV becoming
the youngest artist to ever be signed by
that company she didn't stay with Sony
for long though because she had bigger
dreams to chase like at age 16 her
family moved to Nashville where she was
signed to Big Machine records in 2006.
the record company that pretty much put
her on the map commercially her first
album Taylor Swift was a huge success
what's even crazier is that she legit
wrote those songs herself remember
Teardrops On my guitar and Picture To
Burn yeah she wrote those when she was
in high school impressed yet well the
country music awards were in 2007 Tay
won the CMT award for breakthrough
artist little did they know she was just
getting started Taylor kept on grinding
coming out with her second studio album
Fearless in 2008 the hit single from
that album Love Story stayed on the
Billboard charts for 36 months I get it
that song is a Timeless classic just
like Taylor everyone remembers the 2009
VMAs when Taylor was interrupted during
her acceptance speech for best female
video award though it seems like her and
Kanye patched things up pretty well it's
actually someone's emotions that I
stepped on it was very rude varied
TaylorMade 79 million dollars during The
Fearless tour proving to herself and the
world that she was Unstoppable the world
could not get enough of that album and
in 2010 Taylor won her four Grammys
including album of the year they stayed
humble though in her Grammy acceptance
speech she said I live in awe of the
people that I was nominated against in
this category little did she know these
would be the first of many Grammys in
her future 2011 rolled around which
means another album by now fans were
starting to see a Vibe change for Tay as
she was growing up trading the Sweet
Country Girl look for independent woman
speak now won the Guinness World Record
for fastest selling digital album by a
female artist as well as several Grammys
of course between 22 and we are never
getting back together Taylor's fourth
studio album Red was a pop music tour de
force plus did you hear that I knew you
were trouble was allegedly about Harry
Styles when life gives you lemons right
just kidding I love you Harry shortly
after touring the red album Tay dropped
another chart topper
1989. Shake It Off even reached number
one on the UK chart words in 2016 she
won three more Grammys including album
of the year for the second time in her
life so remember when Tay famously
deleted her Instagram right before
dropping her most daring album yet I
know I do and honestly the album
reputation is still a total Bop
reputation sold 1.2 million copies the
first week it was released Taylor took
reputation for a world tour which turned
out to be the highest grossing Musical
tour in American history she continued
to win more Awards in 2019 she had more
American Music Awards than Michael
Jackson I think that means I can start
calling her the queen of pop music after
a cinematic debut in the 2019 film cats
which was an interesting movie Taylor
released two surprise albums in 2020
folklore and Evermore these albums
explored darker more personal themes
than her previous records following
their release which sold 1 million
copies worldwide in the first week
Taylor put out her very own Netflix
documentary called Miss Americana in the
film Taylor opens up about a lot of
personal things including her experience
with body image issues in the Netflix
film Taylor said picture me where I feel
like I looked like my tummy was too big
and that'll just trigger me to just
starve a little bit and that wasn't the
only time Taylor faced some major
difficulties during her professional
life though big machine records did a
lot for Taylor's career they also owned
their rights to her first six albums in
2019 a record exec named Scooter Braun
bought machine records including all of
Taylor's music she recorded with them
Taylor said in a BBC interview this is
my worst case scenario this is what
happens when you sign a deal at 15. and
despite a long and complicated legal
battle Taylor now has full control of
any of the music she writes and Records
in 2021 she re-recorded her Hit album
fearless and even included six unheard
tracks what a power move and in 2022 she
was back with another studio album
Midnight which is going on tour and like
speaking of Tours did you guys see the
footage from her latest one she sold out
a show to 69 000 fans at the State Farm
Arena in March and believe me those fans
really got their money's worth Taylor
played a 44 song Set over the course of
three hours so amazing the tour is
called Eris which is exactly what the
show's about all of her different
costume changes throughout the set
symbolize the different versions of
herself as she's grown up in the
spotlight okay so what has Taylor done
for herself with all this industry money
well besides put on jaw-dropping live
performances and pouring her heart and
soul into her work she's been able to do
very very well for herself her 600
million dollars net worth has made her
the highest earning female music artist
of all time and she's put that money to
good use sure she owns a couple mansions
in LA and Manhattan two prime private
jets and some really cute cats but she
also donated a lot of her money to a
worthy cause in 2011 she donated seventy
thousand dollars in books to the library
in her hometown in 2021 she also gave
fifty thousand dollars to a family who
lost their father to covet 19. and it
seems like no matter what year it is
Taylor is always in her era of giving
wow is there anything Taylor Swift can't
do doesn't the heiress tour look
absolutely amazing let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to like
And subscribe to the things so you can
stay up to date on all our latest videos
[Music]